(audience applauding)
- Hi.
- So last time you were here,
first of all, you look stunning.
- Thank you, I just-
- So we're just gonna talk about it, yeah.
- Spring is coming,
so I just thought I'd-
- Yeah, it's beautiful.
- Thank you.
- When you were here though,
you were a little teary
because your girls were going to college,
so how are your girls doing now?
- They're still in college,
didn't get kicked out yet.
- Yeah, haven't quite yet...
- My other one is a junior in high school,
and we're starting to look at colleges.
- Yeah oh are you getting
nervous that it's like?
- I am getting nervous.
And it's funny because
I said to my daughter,
I said,
"I've spent basically 18 years
telling you what to do.
Telling you how to be, telling you what."
That's been what,
so now I have to really
allow you to be trusted,
and that's-
- Blossom, make mistakes,
do all the things, yeah.
- Yeah, make mistakes.
- Kind of beautiful?
- It is beautiful,
and they need your trust, you know I mean,
my mom was so-
- You've done a good job
if they're doing a good
job, you know yeah.
- I think so.
I mean, my mom was so different.
She sort of just was held so tightly to me
that I was terrified of being on my own,
and spreading my wings
and finding my independence.
- It was more like codependent?
- Oh it was enmeshment.
And, I was ready to go home.
I missed home so much,
and she sort of did the most unselfish
thing that she could have done, and said,
"You'll never forgive yourself
if you don't see this through.
You're not a quitter."
And that was I think terrible for her,
because it was the beginning
kind of of the end for her,
because her whole identity
was tied up just in loving me.
And we were alone together.
- And your career, and
y'all did everything.
- So she just saw it all kind of go away,
and I think it was really tough for her.
For her own identity, you know?
- Good for her though, pushing you.
And then you're finding your people.
- I mean thank God.
Cause she would've wanted me home anyway.
Like, she missed me so much.
But then I found theater, and I found my-
- [Kelly] Yeah, your group.
- My groups of people,
and different types of people,
and I learned how to think.
And so it was a real place of, for me-
- It's freeing.
- Yeah, it was freeing,
it was terrifying.
But I learned that I had opinions.
It was something that
just didn't occur to me
to have opinions in that industry.
- I keep, absolutely,
especially as a woman.
But it's interesting.
My kids say they're
never leaving my house.
They're like,
"No we're always gonna live with you."
And I'm like,
"First of all, no you're not.
Get a guest house."
And a secondly, I just think you're,
I always tell them, like,
you're not gonna want that.
You're gonna want, my favorite thing was,
one getting my license, freedom.
And then two, getting outta high school
and moving across the country,
and doing stuff, you know what I'm saying?
Like, for you and finding yourself,
I think that's so fun,
the identity of that.
Well the younger one,
I think it's harder for her
to be away from her sister,
but it's also good.
- But also it's just her!
- Yeah it's good.
- Now you're focused.
- But all my stuff keeps disappearing.
- [Kelly] All your stuff
keeps disappearing?
- All my good stuff keeps disappearing.
The face is insane, but-
- I think it's a family thing.
- They always do that thing.
- It's called genetics.
Higher family.
- If I've got a good article of clothing,
like a fancy something, it's always gone.
I gotta go up and I've gotta
recollect all my stuff,
bring it back to my room,
and say,
"Please at least ask me."
- I love that.
(audience cheering)
That was a look at the
new movie about her life.
So your new documentary
is called "Pretty Baby".
So why did now feel like
the right time to make this?
Is it because your kids are older?
Cause do they know about a lot of that?
- They do now,
and they didn't before the documentary,
and that was a mistake.
That was a bad mommy moment for me.
- Really?
- Because I should have
prepped them a little bit more.
But so much of the way we live our life,
is so compartmentalized.
I'm not, we don't live in LA,
we live in the city.
We just, they don't
really know a lot about,
we don't have,
we don't hang out a lot
in sort of the entertainment industry-
- They're not exposed to that, yeah.
- They're not exposed to it,
and they go to regular schools.
So I think I was protecting
them from a lot of that.
But also we were just living our lives,
and I was just mom.
So, I didn't have all my movies on a loop
like a crazy old lady.
- Did just see my work here?
- Look at how funny your mother is.
Oh wait, wait, there's
a good part coming up.
You know and so, I think that they,
I felt, we've been asked many
times to do a documentary.
And they just always either felt like,
either true Hollywood stories,
or where are they now's,
or some more tabloid exploitation.
And George Stephanopoulos
and Ali Wentworth,
their production company,
and I really trusted them.
- Trusted, yeah.
- And they sat me down and said,
"We would like this to be not just you."
This yes, it's all me, the whole show.
But it's the exploration of
sort of sexuality in America.
- Cause it's way more than the
just you when you watch it.
Yeah.
- It's about the
objectification of young women
and sexualization of young women,
and how that shifted-
- And at that time, what was accepted.
- Yeah.
I couldn't make any of
the movies I made now.
- Yeah.
- You couldn't make 'em.
So I thought, okay, if
I'm going to do this
I'm gonna have to implicitly trust.
And I had just archived
all of my material.
My mom kept everything.
So I had a room chockablock full with like
beta half inch, quarter inch,
like I've been around that long
that all the formats were different.
- Oh my God.
- And I digitized everything.
- It's awesome she kept it.
- Oh she kept everything.
And it opened up a whole
conversation between us
that we didn't, amongst us
that we didn't, I don't
know if I would've had.
- That's what I was gonna say.
Cause they didn't know about
the sexual assault, right?
So did they find out like, viewing this?
- My one daughter did, yeah.
And I-
- Wow!
- I-
- How do you bring it up again?
Like, yeah what, so let's talk about..
Yeah no, that's hard.
That's a hard conversation in general.
But what was it like afterwards though?
Because also I think it's a lesson,
like it's a good lesson
for your daughters,
like for all women watching.
- Yes I mean, I think that's,
that is why I chose to include it,
because I couldn't say
that I was doing a full
authentic open documentary
and then just-
- [Kelly] Not be open.
- Be coy about that, or hide that or not.
I needed it to be just honest
and also a teaching moment
or an opportunity to have a conversation.
And my older daughter actually
was privy to to the incident,
my younger daughter wasn't.
And then that was another whole thing.
How come she knew and I didn't know and.
- Yeah.
- And I was trying to say,
but look how healthy we are.
And I am, and I'm not a victim
and this stuff happens.
It's been happening, it
can't happen anymore.
- That's the most remarkable part
can I point that out?
It's the most remarkable thing.
I was talking with my executive producer
my manager this morning,
and I was like it is
incredible watching this
that you did turn out so like sane
and like not on.
A lot of child actors,
especially going through
what you went through
and exposed to things
that you were maybe uncomfortable with
and didn't know to say no
and like didn't even
know what was happening.
Like a lot of those people
go down the line of drugs and alcohol
and like rehab and like,
those people die young.
Like, let's be honest.
Like, so it's remarkable
how amazing you are
and like how just even you are,
like balanced you are.
- Wow, thank you.
(audience applauding)
- I think it's in it's incredible.
- Thank you.
- And I also think I I
love that you said it,
I don't carry the victim mentality.
Like it's not, not a victim,
you're a survivor of something.
- Right.
And it's how you move forward
through these things in your life.
And I do a tribute a lot to my mother
because she did keep me out of the mania
and it, that was the paradox.
She put me in certain situations
and that people had a problem with.
And I understand that.
- Yeah.
- And then the flip side is
I was really protected in
a very interesting way.
And she was such an raging
alcoholic, not a rager
but a very hardcore alcoholic.
And my whole focus was keeping her alive.
So I had this-
- Which is a weight that should not be on.
- Absolutely I mean,
there's that one moment
where I stick up for her
and it's the way the press treated us
and what was acceptable, whether it's,
asking me my measurements
on nationwide television
asking me to stand up.
Barbara Walters did that
and compared herself to me.
And just this sort of the
approach that they had
in asking me questions as a 12 year old
was really just unconscionable
and to see that-
- It like stirs rage in me.
- It does, it does.
I mean, as a mom too,
it just breaks my heart
to see that little girl.
But I went to regular
schools, I went to college
I always had this knowledge that
if I don't have something
that's gonna keep me grounded,
I'm gonna get eaten up by this business.
I am going to just get lost in it.
And it's gonna, it's
going to obliterate me.
And then what will I have?
And I knew I needed something grounding.
I knew I needed the family.
- Maybe that's what saved you
is stepping outside of that.
- Absolutely.
- And doing something more normal.
- And just seeing another world and not,
and being a kid,
the having that sort of experience.
And then I also wanted to win,
do you know what I mean?
I wanted to prove to other people,
but to myself, that you can't,
I'm right here and I have
grown into this person
and I'm like a weevil,
you're not gonna knock me over.
I'm gonna come right back.
- I love that.
(audience applauding)
You had success very early on
but then you said you went to college.
So like, after that,
like after you graduated
what was it like, getting back in,
it was harder right?
- Oh, huh.
I was-
- She said, "Oh huh."
- So known non grata.
I was so shocked
because basically the
entire industry was like,
oh no, we're good.
We, you've been away,
and then in that, in the interim,
a whole new crop of young
actresses and actors
sort of came up
and they were the hot thing.
And I had gained weight in college
and I was sort of in this stage
where I was a bit awkward
and it just, I couldn't get a job.
I mean, I literally ended up
having to do weird commercials
in other languages in other countries
just to pay the bills.
And it was such a shock
but I ended up studying.
I just started studying.
I started dancing, I started taking class
I started studying acting,
which I'd never done before.
- Yeah.
- And one of my first
jobs back was Broadway,
was "Grease", on Broadway.
And then-
- Being on stage is,
for me, I love being
on stage in that sense
the live aspect of like,
going straight through.
And I love that feeling.
I think that energy is so cool.
- And you can find, I mean
I've done shows for six
months, a year at a time.
And you can find something.
You do the same shows, same blocking.
- But it's different.
- [Brooke] Different every night.
- I know yeah.
- So it was just fun.
And it was fun to be a part of a company.
So I came out of college-
- It's like a family.
- And, yeah very much.
I mean, but I came out of college
and nobody really wanted to hire me.
And it was very difficult ego wise
it was very difficult,
bill wise paying keeping up,
by then my mom was just,
she just like bought houses
every time we made movies
she'd buy a house.
And we had all this
property and no capital.
And it was,
it was a real shock and I just thought,
okay, I'm gonna have to start.
What am I gonna do now?
And we had no plan.
We just needed to buy a car.
So I would do this movie or whatever,
there was no real thought process.
- One thing I also love about you,
because I have a lot of friends
that have suffered from
postpartum depression
and people don't understand it
if you've never experienced it, right.
Like, even them describing to me,
like I never really quite,
you can't get what someone's feeling.
And I love how not only
you were open about it
but then people came against you about it
and you ended up writing
the op-ed about it.
I think that that is so important
and I know it's not easy to do,
like you said it's not easy to do
when you're an actress in the public
or anybody in the public eye.
People are like, just shut up and sing,
or shut up and act like you know,
they don't want you to
have an opinion about anything.
And even though you're human in a society
and living with everybody else,
but it was so, it's so important
because not a lot of people
have a voice for that.
And you have a giant spotlight on you.
So for you to not only
stand up for yourself,
but stand up for all those other women,
it was incredible.
And it's like one of my favorite
things you've ever done.
(audience applauding)
And it just takes, it takes a lot of guts
to do something like that and bravery,
is it, was it easy for you to...
Do you do well in situations like that?
You know what I'm saying?
- I think writing a book is a very
introverted sort of action.
You sort of, you really do have to sit
with you, your thoughts
and really kind of be willing to go there.
So that was a very
comfortable endeavor for me.
Telling the story it didn't feel,
I don't know if it was courageous,
but it was necessary.
And I think that as a mother of a daughter
at the time now two daughters,
I owe it to them to be,
to tell the truth about something
that is so frightening.
So many people suffer,
untreated it can be devastating.
And really just to say,
I don't wanna feel alone.
I can't be the only one feeling this.
- Yeah.
- Please and I was a plea as well
for people to, for,
to learn that I wasn't alone.
And that, and the power in
being able to ask for help
and there's no shame in it.
And I think that's not the way, I grew up
you just stiff upper lip and you just,
show must go on and that's what you do.
And this undid me.
And when I started doing research on it,
I thought someone's gotta tell this story
because people and families are suffering.
- Yeah.
- The people around who love
the person going through it
they don't know what to do.
They don't know how to fix it
because it doesn't and it's custom made.
It is custom made to each person.
And it's brilliant
because it answers all
the negative questions
and they all, it is an
imbalance, it's biochemical
and you feel that that word crazy
keeps being floated around you
and you just keep thinking
what's wrong with me?
People have been having
babies since the dawn of time
and they gaze down at their infant
and their hair cascades
and the baby looks up and,
all's well with the world.
- Angel are singing.
- Angels are singing.
- And everything's perfect.
- And it's just, it's a lot harder.
And I just wanted to be
able to be honest about it
because I knew nobody
was talking about this
and I thought I refused
to find shame in this.
I need to get through this.
- I love that you say it's like a plea
and like reaching out as well.
- [Brooke] Absolutely.
- That's what living is about connecting,
I think and relationships
- And making it okay.
- [Kelly] Those bigger conversations.
- And again, it's tough
but it's, you can get through these things
and ask for help, you know?
- Absolutely.
(audience applauding)